bonsoir je vais vous parler d'un voyage
un voyage sur le parcours de ma vie ce
voyage m'a appris à penser autrement
autrement sur quoi ou bien sûr qui est
bien ce soir j'ai choisi de vous parler
d'enfants et tout particulièrement
d'enfants avec autisme
je travaille depuis treize ans avec des
enfants autistes et il faut savoir que
j'ai trouvé chez eux bon nombre de
capacités dans mon histoire je vais vous
parler plus particulièrement de timothée
à l'époque où je vous parle de lui il
avait 7 ans et avec un retard mental
grave lorsque je travaille j'ai une
technique bien particulière j'ai une
démarche qui s'appelle une démarche
holistique c'est à dire avoir un point
de vue d'ensemble d'un individu et pour
travailler dans cette démarche
j'ai ont un système sur lequel je
travaille en permanence
c'est à dire la perception le sensoriel
l'émotionnel le comportement ensuite on
a toute la partie autour de la
commission du corps
pour aller un petit peu plus loin sur ce
que je propose est bien faut savoir que
je me fixe des critères de travail et
sur ces critères le premier c'est de me
fier à leur sens et leur sens uniquement
il est extrêmement important pour moi de
voir de recevoir et de ressentir un
autre critère bien important ça va être
que toute action ou réactions ont un
sens c'est à dire que ce n'est pas ce
que je connais puisque certains marchent
sur la pointe des pieds
alors que d'autres vont faire tourner
des toupies de façon incessante
mais c'est à moi découvrir le lien entre
action et réaction afin de leur donner
une opportunité de vie il va falloir que
je potentialise ses enfants les
pantalons les potentialiser sur notre
intelligence
ça c'est extrêmement important
et puis un autre critère ça va être
l'opportunisme et ça c'est extrêmement
important l'opportunisme parce que ça va
me permettre d'aller surveiller chaque
est un sel d'action afin de mieux
comprendre et de mieux percevoir ce
qu'ils ont à me montrer un des derniers
critères que je m'impose c'est de me
dire qu'ils sont tous en capacité
d'accéder aux apprentissages
peu importe leur différence peu importe
leur taux de handicap
ce qui est important pour moi à ce
moment-là c'est de leur offrir un chemin
de vie possible et donc de créer des
leviers et des outils qui leur
permettent de trouver ce chemin
si on veut aller un petit peu plus loin
sur ce voyage et qu'on puisse partager
un carnet ensemble et bien je dirais
qu'il sera très très important de
changer notre perception juste là
quelques instants et dans ce schéma de
perception
je voudrais vous montrer c'est un
autrement parce que la réalité elle est
très différente de les yeux d'un enfant
ce n'est pas la réalité qui est la nôtre
en tant qu'adulte où nous on va regarder
l'enfant du bas du haut vers le bas la
réalité que je vous demande adoptée
c'est la réalité d'un enfant celle qui
regarde vers le haut elle est très
différente et c'est très haut c'est
celle ci je voudrais vous gardiez au
moins quelques instants afin d'entrevoir
les ressources qu'il existe dans chaque
enfant c'est ça l'important
alors du coup ça me donne envie de vous
partager une carte postale et la
première c'est la perception visuelle
la première question va est de vous
demander ce que vous voyez est là bien
souvent ce que l'on voit sur ces images
c'est une voiture mais l'enfant dont je
vous parle
voyez bien plus que tout cela il voyait
des milliers d'éléments isolés qui lui
permettait de faire des choses
magnifiques avec alors un jour comme il
adore car ce jeu lui propose un livre de
collection panini et je lui demande de
poser les images à l'intérieur ce qui
est important noté c'est qu'à l'époque
où j'ai observé cet enfant il ne
connaissait pas la nuit suite numérique
est d'ailleurs pas d'importance puisque
de toute façon il ne regardait jamais le
verso de l'image et pourtant je les
observe et il me donne 98 % de taux de
bonnes réponses
il a placé correctement les images sur
les pages de son livre absolument
extraordinaire donc on est on regarde on
observe on va plus loin on cherche à
savoir comment il a pu faire et là d'un
seul coup je perçois qu'il a analysé le
travail de l'infographie
tout simplement avec les milliers
détails que lui voyait ça lui avait
permis de découvrir le premier plan le
second plan les indices visuels et comme
il avait vu énormément de points communs
entre les images et les pages il avait
associé formidable eh bien il faut
savoir que je suis allé plus loin
je vais les regarder du côté de la
communication et c'est l'objet de notre
deuxième carte postale et là on pourrait
amener à adma se demander comment un
enfant qui ne parlent pas peut demander
un gâteau un jour cet enfant vient me
voir et il me montre un livre en me
montrant sur le livre un gâteau et je
lui dis tu en veux il me prend la main
et alors nous voilà partis main dans la
main partie partagé est un super gâteau
c'était bon c'est ça la communication
différencier bien souvent on attache la
communication à ce que nous pouvons
produire la communication verbale
il faut savoir que des moyens de
communication il y en a absolument
énormément lui il avait choisi l'image
et pour aller au delà
et bien moi je vous propose une
troisième carte postale les
comportements restreint ce sont les
comportements dans lequel les individus
avec autisme vont se restreindre c'est à
dire que cet enfant là avait l'habitude
de faire tourner des toupies mais alors
faire tourner des toupies ses 4 5 heures
d'affilée non-stop
ça monte et ça descend de manière
régulière et incessantes
c'est très difficile là en fer en sortir
mais moi ce que j'avais entrepris
c'était lui faire découvrir un puzzle je
me rappelle encore un puzzle 12 pièces
avec de très grosses pièces j'ai essayé
essayé essayé encore est rien il ne
voulait pas le faire
et j'ai essayé en le montrant des fois
j'allais chatouiller essayant de lui
montrer un au delà essayer de le guider
vers ailleurs d'autres fois encore ce
que j'ai fait c'était de lui donner des
stratégies pour voir s'ils pouvaient
s'en inspirer mais il m'a guère montrés
bien autre chose
et un jour en ré essayant une énième
fois ils me regardent ils me souffle
dessus tu me saoules est là et bien je
vous avoue qu'il ya un grand silence qu
arrive on est un peu stupéfaits ils mes
cartes de son chemin sur le vin vers le
placard et il prend 1 2 3 puzzle de 50
pièces là je me dis mais c'est pas
possible il en a jamais fait j'ai jamais
vu cet enfant faire un puzzle est gentil
non me voilà à vider ses boîtes les
poussées et l'or là d'un seul coup je
vois un enfant qui enchaîne pièce par
pièce ligne par ligne
c'était absolument hallucinant j'ai
découvert qu'il était une véritable
machine à tricoter du puzzle j'avais
jamais vu ça de ma vie
neuf minutes 12 c'est le temps qu'il lui
a fallu pour la première fois pour faire
150 pièces avec 3 puzzle différents moi
je vous dis qu'entre voir différemment
c'est absolument formidable et tout ceci
m'amène à une quatrième carte postale et
cette quatrième par carte postale et
bien c'est le plaisir le désir et les
limites quelque chose que l'on connaît
bien
alors je vais vous demander si vous avez
envie de sortir
ou alors une autre question est ce que
le fait de penser à sortir vous donne du
plaisir
eh bien il faut savoir qu'à sept enfants
il en était certain
sortir il le voulait je veux je veux
sortir alors on y allait on partait et
puis en partant on était heureux dans la
voiture tout se passait bien mais
seulement au moment où ge ouvrait la
portière à côté de cette grande rue
alors là c'était terminé
peur écrit il était absolument
bouleversés alors on rentre on analyse
on observe qu est ce qui a pu modifier
le comportement de cet enfant qu'est ce
qui a pu faire qu'il en arrive là
du bonheur à la limite c'était
absolument extrême alors on y retourne
on réessaie et d'un seul coup on
entrevoit un peu différemment parce que
là c'était le bruit en mouvement qui
perturbe est cette enfant un bruit lourd
extrêmement lourd
c'est peut être présent
extrêmement oppressant est ce que vous
avez ressenti un peu ça le mouvement
vous avez du mal à identifier les
visages ça bouge ça grouille et bien
pour lui c'était un véritable capharnaüm
son plaisir l'amener à sa limite
alors il fallait que je trouve un moyen
pour contourner cette limite
mais avant de contourner il faut penser
à trouver un juste équilibre entre
motivation et limites afin que lui
puisse se mettre en oeuvre et une fois
après alors quand on en arrive au chemin
du contournement il fallait que j
apprenne que dans son coeur dans son
corps et dans son esprit il y avait là
les outils qui lui permettrait d'aller
au delà
alors moi je peux vous dire que ces
enfants m'ont énormément appris ils
m'ont appris à comprendre et le fait de
comprendre et bien ça me permet de
m'ajuster
c'est ça mon travail je m'adapte à ses
enfants
je m'adapte à leur état de perception
c'est extrêmement important
timothée quant à lui m'avait permis de
voir qu'il avait un pic de compétences
dans l'intelligence mécanique et
informatique et qu'à chaque fois qu'il a
été en surcharge émotionnelle ou
sensoriel en fait ils réutilisent s est
intelligent cela dans sa limite
il faisait monter et descendre ses
toupies s'harmoniser lui il avait bien
essayé aux travailleurs de sa toupie
mais ça ne suffisait pas il n'avait pas
trouvé le bon chemin et c'est là où
rentrent en action
voilà car aujourd'hui le fait de lui
avoir montré un autre chemin possible
lui permet s'ouvrir et s'épanouir
l'important il est là
ensuite en ce qui concerne la démarche
holistique
je dirais qu'il faut aller bien plus
loin que ce que je vous ai dit au début
c'est à dire qu'il faut aller au delà
d'avoir un point de vue d'ensemble de
l'enfant puisque l'objectif il est de
trouver des liens opérant et de ses
liens d'opéra il faut absolument aller
construire des projets éducatifs et
pédagogiques qui leur permettent
d'entrevoir un autre chemin possible de
cela en découlent tout un avenir
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
chacun d'entre eux est en capacité de
s'épanouir
ils m'ont permis de voir qu'il fallait
absolument aller au-delà de ce que nous
voyons
car chacun d'entre eux peut arriver à
surmonter ses difficultés parce qu'ils
sont tous différents mais universel à la
fois je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
d'un voyage d'un carnet de voyage
j'espère vous avoir donné autant de
bonheur que j'ai pu en recevoir de vous
ce soir en vous le partageant il ya un
élément que je ne vous ai pas livré
encore c'est par rapport à timothée ce
que je veux vous dire ce soir c'est que
timothée c'est mon fils il a 13 ans
aujourd'hui ils rentrent au collège et
il est heureux
ce que je pourrais vous dire c'est que
dans mon cadre professionnel à
aujourd'hui
et bien cette démarche holistique cette
façon de voir ne permet de trouver des
solutions nouvelles
des postures des gestes afin de leur
trouver un nouveau chemin de vie voilà
merci